as a jacket enthusiast and
a part of whitney's developing coven i'm
gonna do something i've dreamed of for
so long today and go through
her jacket closet comics like jackets
are a big deal to us
they are it makes it look like we know
how to put together an outfit
that's right when really we just wear
the same thing like a cartoon character
and then put a different jacket on these
jackets tell the story of a 15-year
journey
of a female stand-up comedian her
evolution her ups her downs her rises
her falls uh and did you host singled
out
you know what i'm gonna lean into my
feminine side
i'm gonna be twee and dainty
and not shy away from my femininity did
you wear this for something
it's a cute jacket i stand by this one
actually
really yes i do so if i put this on
it's gonna look cute oh put it oh i mean
put it on
heaven is it adorable is it though
you're slouching on purpose to make it
look like i am not slashing on purpose
making your body look bad just
right in this is the meanest video i've
ever had to make i am actually trying to
sell this thing
okay suck it stop trying to this is what
i would wear
so cute this is what i would i did wear
a version of this
this is a vintage baseball jacket that i
got and i want to say nashville at a
vintage
love it store it's great yeah you can
have that
i have one very similar to it i can have
this yeah you can have that
i mean i'll take it yeah you just so
good am i making my body look better
that's so good no you're not so that was
a joke
i mean i'm gonna think about it for
three years i just here's the problem i
have to
if your ego gets too big you'll stop
being funny so i just have to keep you
hating yourself you're protecting
that's what i'm here that's what a
mentor does when did you sell real
estate
in orange county
this is um a very divorced
i mean this is like this is a jacket
that says my heart is broken
and i'm gonna get back out there but no
one's gonna hurt me
and i did get half the money thank you
for asking
this is like when i was like okay
there's a way to be like
a vulnerable trucker you're the key
i mean it's comfy being a female
comedian is to not have to need a purse
and so i like to wear things with big
pockets i i mean we love them because
it has to fit your phone your set list
in the tissues to wipe your face off
when you cry
this blazer new year's eve this was rode
hard and put away
wet there were pants to go with it but i
split them
this is so much better than the other
blazers black tank top jeans
heels so cool you're the coolest person
in the room
this is when i assume
when you were a professor who was
inappropriate with his students
i'm going to step back because this is
pretty chic
is it no i swear to god this is actually
working more than you think it is
but it's not for onstage what is this
for this is like
hipster brooklyn dream girl and you pair
it with shorts that go to like here
okay all right i could see that and you
like roll these yes it's it's very
um messy bun catherine hepburn coffee
cup
with your hair this color is heaven this
is like
sporty like i'm married but everyone
knows i'm gay except me
this is like you know what i caught my
husband cheating but we got past it this
is what
the lesbian soccer coach wears to the
awards ceremony
horse queen yes that's right you yes
this is the most whitney jacket i've
ever seen in my life horse
as a female comic like sneakers are your
only option you get don't get to be
glamorous so you just have to have as
fancy sneakers as possible
oh these have been through a lot
speaking of going through a lot
who you know there was a minute where i
was like i think i'm this guy
like am i this person am i are you a
picnic table
am i a pedophile in the 70s are you the
music man coming through the small town
i oh i got it from a vintage store and
it just smells
uh-huh like a memory polio like a
repressed memory
this was i'm gonna like take matters
into my own hands and be a wedding
planner
uh i wore this a lot like on tour
cincinnati pensacola you recognize this
jacket
this is my vintage audrey hepburn it's
very cute
vibes jacket that is i do like i mean
i'm sure it looks crazy with the amount
of pink i mean if you're going for a
manic pixie dream girl
this is it manic i didn't you added that
that's what the phrase is i said pixie
dream girl you added manic
you took away manic oh yeah this is like
that might it's too small for me then
it's going to be too small for me to try
it
you're like setting me up to hate my
body i know i'm trying to make you hurt
yourself
okay i mean for sure this is
come on oh okay i have one boob it looks
like you do no
this is how conservatives feel when they
wear masks
this is cool it's by the way it also
looks like it's for a small child
i like it i ordered it thinking it was
gonna be my new thing
i was like i'm gonna be like an alt
comic who people like respect
yeah this is not gonna fit me you know
what it doesn't
yeah it doesn't fit me either it doesn't
it's going in the right direction
it's it's almost fitting you're right if
it were slightly bigger
from c oh my god are you kidding me
the tag says sears boys
you got this in the boys section of
sears
i ordered it from a thrift store first
of all i don't see gender
second of all second of all the
children's section of sears this could
get me on megan's law
frankly what about this no but i don't
that's a great
jacket rails you know is my face this is
good i use i wear
their shirts on stage all the time the
plaid ones it's like letting everybody
know that i do want to date younger men
but i'm not like hunting them on the
prowl
it's like i prefer men that are 25 but
i'm not gonna like harass them i'm not
gonna like
you guys come to me like it's not quite
cheetah prince
uh-huh you know yes this is a very
subtle
cougar sweatshirt with just chains on it
for no reason
i like that oh this is fun oh it's so
good it's so funny it's so much better
than you and it
hits right where you like things to hit
yeah just the kinkiest sweater
i've ever it looks really good
when you finish something you're just
like
and we're done this is this is the only
noise you'll tolerate during sex
i learned that if i want things in your
closet i have to suggest we do a video
about it
and i'll walk away with a whole new
wardrobe um and i learned
how many people you've been over the
course of your career
you